hi there have you ever wondered how
video game levels are made yeah me
neither
but this paper has and in this paper you
can see a reinforcement learning agent
that has learned how to make video game
levels in various ways so this is
implemented for this game here where the
goal is simply to make the longest maze
this game here is an adaptation to the
Legend of Zelda where you have to get a
key to the door and this game here is
called a tsuba con where you have to put
all of the crates onto the green squares
in order to solve it so it's a puzzle
game alright and this is done via
reinforcement learning so the paper
we're going to look at is called PC GRL
procedural content generation via
reinforcement learning by Ahmed Khalifa
fili Bontrager Sam early and Julian toga
Leo's now this paper is basically just a
fun paper and I feel and it shows how to
frame a problem in terms of
reinforcement learning and then how to
solve it it's pretty straightforward
it's fairly short and I you know the
codes available and all so you can go
check it out yourself they say we
investigate how reinforcement learning
can be used to train level designing
agents okay so usually usually you we do
reinforcement learning for playing games
in themselves and now we use
reinforcement learning to train an agent
that can design a level so we don't
design the level itself straightforward
we design the agent that designs the
level and what's the advantage here the
advantages of course the agent could
then put potentially generate multiple
different levels once we have trained it
let's say this represents a new approach
to procedural content generation in
games where level design is framed as a
game itself so the design of the level
is now the game
and the content generator itself is
learned by seeing the design problem as
a sequential task we can use
reinforcement learning to learn how to
take the next action so that the
expected final level quality is
maximized this approach can be used when
few or no examples exist to train from
and the Train generator is very very
fast okay so this is the outset of the
of the problem formulation now we're
going to go through the steps you have
to do in order to make this work there
are a few things that I think this paper
does quite well and yeah so the first
thing is you actually have to frame the
problem in terms of reinforcement
learning so what is reinforcement
learning is pretty simple in
reinforcement learning you have this
agent environment split okay so at each
step the environment is going to send
the agent and observation so the
environment is going to send an
observation to the agent and the agent
needs to take an action in response to
that now something happens in here that
we don't we don't worry about that and
the environment is going to send the
next observation okay that is a result
from taking this action and it is also
going to send the reward for this action
so at each step the agent gets an
observation and the reward for the last
action took and it has yet but the next
action now the environment of course has
to somehow decide how do I represent the
observation this is the representation
how do I transform one observation to
the next observation given an action ok
the action comes in and transforms the
last state to the next state and then
how do I give the reward how do I
calculate the reward so these things are
the things you have to decide on the
observation space how the reward is
calculated the action space and how an
action transforms one representation
into the next representation so this is
what we're going to look at the
different variants
we're not going to look at specifically
how reinforcement learning is done
because once you have an environment
like this you can just plug it into a
standard reinforcement learning
algorithm and it will solve it for you
ok so that's the power of basically
having standardized or representations
so the observation space of this problem
is going to be pretty simple all the
games we're dealing with here are in
this I already did some drawings are in
this in this framework of this great
world game ok so you have this you have
this grid this level is subdivided into
this grid and that naturally corresponds
of course to a 2d matrix now each point
in this matrix has a number and the
number describes what type of tile this
tile is so as you can see right here the
one is going to be a wall while the zero
is going to be empty space three here is
one of these crates and two is the
player so you get the point right each
number corresponds to a type of of tile
so far so good that's the observation
space now what is the action space what
is the what the agent can do at each
step they say the agent can change one
of these tiles okay so you can change
one of these tiles let's say this one
right here it can change it to a
different one or you can just leave it
so this is a wall right now and it makes
the problem fairly interesting you have
a wall right here in the middle so we're
since we're looking at this tile we
might just want to leave this right
there we could also change it we can
actually change it such that 2 a 2 a 2
such that there is another player right
here right let me can I even draw this
this yellow isn't such that there is now
two player tiles in the game this would
of course be an invalid level and the
reinforcement learning agent ultimately
should learn to produce valid and good
levels okay so at each step you can
change one tile and of course the goal
is to make a better and better and
better level over time now how how do
you choose which
Tyl - to change that's the thing you
have to define and they define three
different ways where in which the agent
can choose which tile the change in the
narrow formulation they themselves so
the environment chooses the frame the
the tile to change so the environment
will say now you can change this tile if
you want and then the next step it will
say now you can change this one if you
want now you can change this one if you
want now this is completely random okay
how the environment actually doesn't
have to be but the environment chooses
and that is problematic for the agent
because the agent cannot kind of predict
which tile it could change next and
therefore it cannot really plan ahead
how it wants to change the level it can
only make very very local very greedy
choices it can be like oh I'm I'm right
here I might I might actually build a
wall right here yes that seems good but
it can't so an example is maybe you want
to make the level more interesting maybe
you think that the crate up here is a
bit close to this field here you have to
push it on to this field and that's
fairly easy right so you just push it
like up and then to the left actually
it's not that easy because there's the
wall right here and you have to go
around actually you'd happen probably
have to push this down but let's say the
level is too easy and you want to move
the move the crate to a bit like let's
say here in this in this framework where
the environment tells you which fate
which which tiles to change you can
basically once you come across this tile
you can delete it okay but then you can
have to wait and wait and wait and wait
until at random the style where you want
to put it is selected and this might
actually never happen because the
episode might be over and if it never
happens you are in an invalid level
right so the ID the agent here is
basically forced to greedily make the
level valid before it can make it in
interesting and then it can only make it
interesting in sort of local ways so the
second way that the second formulation
here is the turtle formulation now you
might know this from the turtle graphics
where basically you have this you have
this little turtle thing and you can
always move it either like you know down
up left or right and then you can always
put a dot or not put a dot and thereby
you can like trace out things this is
like intro to programming same here
so now the agent is given a starting
Square and it can choose to change it or
not but it can also choose how to move
to the next square so to the right up
left or down it can so it can choose so
you can go along and say okay now I'm
here I want to change it to a - now I'm
here and so on so it can basically do
things like build long walls and things
like this so you can plan ahead more
considerably but still if you regard the
problem from before if it wants to place
the misplaced the crate to a different
location it can like if maybe it's here
okay the agent is here and then it can
say okay I want to not change but move
and not to change and move no change
move and then you can delete and then it
has to move over here step by step until
it can place it again it's so you can
plan ahead considerably longer actually
you can just move straight over because
the agent itself is not constrained by
walls so I can move ahead quite a bit
but it's still kind of localized changes
because it can move one tile at a time
right and if in between the episode ends
it's again an invalid level so the third
formulation is the most powerful
formulation it's called the wide
formulation and this is where the agent
at each time step cannot only choose how
to change the tile but can freely choose
the next tile to change so it can make
it say in one step it could say I want
to delete
this style and then in the next step we
could say I want to place it right here
okay so this is so it can plan ahead
considerably so how you design the
action space is very important for how
your agent or for what your agent can
possibly learn and how easy it is for
the agent to learn because it's gonna be
pretty easy for this agent to learn to
move crates like this where even though
the other agent that moves one tile at a
time can also do it it has to plan ahead
for longer so it has to sort of invest
more of the reinforcement learning power
into doing these sorts of things but of
course it's being more constrained also
means you have less actions at your
disposal like this last agent it has a
lot of actions it can do it can choose
any tile at once right so that can also
introduce considerable exploration a
dilemma and you have to trade these
things off when you design things like
that alright so this is the action space
now how the observation involves evolves
into the next observation should be
fairly clear I mean that's already given
by the action space if you ask yourself
if you're in this in this situation
right here and the agent deletes the
crate then the crate is no longer there
then so if it changes this to a zero
then it's just empty space now okay so
that's that's fairly obvious here now
the last thing we need to do is the
reward calculation what reward do you
give the agent and you can here you can
give the agent the reward either let's
say at the very end you cannot give it a
reward for the entire episode and give
it a reward at the very end
reinforcement learning algorithms are
able to deal with this to a certain
degree you can also decide to give it at
each step now the way they do it here I
believe is they give it at the end and
they have multiple components to the
reward so the reward in this case is how
well the level fulfills certain goals
that the programmer sets so the goals in
soap
are basically the rules of the game and
that means there is only one player if
there are two or none then the reward is
less there are at least one crate and
there are as many crates as Greenfields
okay so here you can see there are only
two crates but three Greenfields so the
agent will get a penalty for producing a
level like this and then the last thing
is the level has to be solvable and for
checking solve ability the the authors
of this paper simply employ a so borken
solver they have a so become solver that
is a like a tree search algorithm that
tries to solve the level if it can't
solve the level then the level is
invalid and the agent gets a a worse
reward than whenever the level is
solvable okay now how you design the
reward is also very important if you
only give to give like a one reward when
all the goals are fulfilled and give a
zero reward as soon as one of the goals
is not fulfilled a reinforcement
learning agent is going to have a very
very much difficult time to learn that
so you have to kind of design the reward
so if you help the agent realize what's
important so maybe if there's only one
crate missing but you know in fact the
level is solvable except for that you
know that maybe one green field is going
to be empty then you could still give a
fairly high reward but you could just
give a higher reward when the level is
actually solvable like or all the rules
are forfeit fulfilled and there is a
crate here okay
the other thing to notice here is that
in this case you actually do need a
solver for the level since it's a puzzle
game and that means your level your
agent is currently going to produce
levels that are as difficult as your
solver can solve so that's going to be a
considerable problem but that's you know
a limitation here but all of their
rewards are hard-coded so to say so
there is the reward is given by the
environment so now that we have
observations which are these matrices
right here we have actions which and we
actually have three diff
ways of formulating actions and we have
reward they can simply plug this into a
standard reinforcement learning
algorithm now they have one last thing
that they have which is this change
percentage parameter so what they say is
they give the agent an initial state and
then the agent is allowed to change it
around like here so on the left you have
this initial state okay this is sort of
a random initial State and you allow the
agent now to change it in this stepwise
fashion and you always update the agent
by the way the agent as you can might
imagine the agent takes this matrix
right here and puts it shoves it through
like a few convolutional layers and then
decides on an action almost forgetting
that this this is so obvious by now that
yeah the agent is like a standard deep
learning taking in a 2d doing some
convolutions and then having like a
policy output yeah so you shove this
into a proximal policy optimization
algorithm which is the standard
reinforcement learning algorithm and you
allow to change these things now what
they do is they only allow the agent to
change the levels by so much because
what they say is if we start out from
these different states we would you can
decide on two things either the you can
train the agent to find you the best
possible level ever right but then it
would sort of ignore the starting State
it would just learn which level gives me
the highest reward and it would just
change all the tiles always to that
right it would just try to change the to
always reach that best possible state
and forget the start state so they say
okay well the the last constraint is the
agent can only change like 20% of the
tiles at most and after after that we
end the episode or we just don't allow
the agent to change anything anymore it
needs to first so if it changed this
here to empty space and wants to change
something else it first needs to change
this back and then it can change
something else so you can do that so
this constrains the agent and kind of
teaches it that in order to get a higher
it must sort of adjust the starting
state to something that gets higher
reward and that's one way of making the
D levels that you generate more diverse
it's sort of a unique problem to this
particular kind of reinforcement
learning problem because I'll sometimes
like most of the time you just want to
find the highest reward whatever but
here you also want to you know maximize
diversity of the levels you generate and
therefore you could say that's that's a
pretty good you know that's a pretty
good constraint to put into that so
that's a thing I like here about this
paper this this change percentage
constraint now at inference time you can
change that so at training time you only
change whatever 20 percent but at
inference time you can technically that
the agent run for longer as you can see
I think here they just let it run until
it you know find something good like
this one right here fairly good from
this starting state and you can see it
sort of still adjusts to the starting
state right here so you can see that
this it connects the the two dots on the
top so the goal is to make the longest
possible maze or a long maze so it
connects these two you can see here also
this one connects them so and then it
goes out here and connects to this one
so it's fairly good at relying on this
starting state now you can see that
these turtle and wide representations
that can actually choose where to go and
where to change something here
considerably or you know more more
powerful than this narrow thing
especially if you look at this level
right here which again is the importance
of designing the action space well is
going to directly affect the outcome
that you're going to have all right and
you see it the same thing here for this
Zelda game now here you can see the
starting state often involves let's say
here you have two players and you have
three keys and that's an invalid
starting state and sometimes the the DOE
or cannot be reached sometimes the door
is actually not even there like here and
you can see that the agent all of the
agents sort of learn to make at least
valid levels where you have the player
and the door and the key right here
being able to reach everything so that's
you know fairly fairly cool because
counting is one of these things that the
neural networks aren't necessarily super
good at so it's nice to see that you
know they can they can hear they have
two players and they they're deleting
one of them here they have three crates
and they actually make it such that the
number of crates and the number of green
tiles agree so you know that's that's
fairly cool that this comes out and here
you can see the different power of the
algorithms so in this binary problem and
this is the zelda problem this is so
become problem you can see that as you
allow the agent at inference time to
change more and more of the level the
percentage of levels where the agent
gets a good gets a good level like
succeeds in building a valid level goes
up and up and now this as I'd already
said this narrow representation here
appears to be a bit less powerful than
the others interestingly in so become
the best one is this turtle
representation where you can only change
one tile at a time and not the more
powerful wide representation as probably
because I'm going to guess that's
because the either the reinforcement
learning algorithm was isn't you know
powerful enough or their representation
like the CNN is maybe miss architectured
a bit you know technically this
representation should be able to achieve
higher scores but not as easily because
as I said the action space is so much
higher so it's more difficult to learn
but ultimately it should learn it better
all right so this is
this was this paper it's I think it's
fairly cool and fairly fun to view it
from this particular perspective and
they discuss that the future could be
that humans solve this together because
usually when you have assisted level
design you would have something some
sort of like an optimizer running to
optimize the level you're working on
directly like you'd say okay make
something here and it would sort of run
for a while and that takes you know it
takes time now this here this agent at
inference time is very very fast so it
can you know work together with humans
so the human would say for example oh
here please make a wall right here
because that's gonna make the level more
interesting but make it such that the
level is still you know interesting and
solvable and then the the agent can you
know go across do some things that's
gonna be super fast and agents and
humans could work together at this now
one drawback of course is that in a
puzzle game like soba con you know you
have to make sure the level is solvable
and here luckily you can employ a solve
a solver but as the puzzles get more
difficult that's not not super like
that's not gonna be the case that much
and also they remarked that most of the
levels generated are fairly easy because
their reward only depends on whether or
not the level is solvable by an easy
solver right so you could give some
reward for how difficult the level is
but then again that depends on your
solver so an interesting next step would
be to evolve these or to train these as
you train reinforcement learning agents
to solve these kinds of games so kind of
do a curriculum learning sort of a Gans
setting in between level generator and
reinforcement learning algorithm like
reinforcement learning game player to to
sort of evolve levels and agents at the
same time I think it's sort of like this
poet approaches except you would
directly learn I think that would be
next nice direction for this work in any
case the code is available you can even
plug in your own
games and make your own levels so check
this out and with that I'll see you next
time bye-bye